merci à tous d'être là les amours merci
à Valérie benaïve aussi qui est la ma
chérie comment ça va ça va génial il
fait beau c'est magnifique en blanc
comme ça c'est le James Bond tunisien
[Rires]
commençons ce journal par les images de
l'intervention des pompiers de Paris
dans les ruines de l'immeuble qui vient
alors d'exploser rue Saint-Jacques hier
très vite vous le voyez ils activent les
lances à incendies pour éteindre le feu
puis il se concentre sur les recherches
dans les gravats des recherches qui ont
permis d'extirper des victimes de cet
amas de pierre et de bois et votre
hypothèse alors c'est pas le moment
votre hypothèse le votre hypothèse
j'ai un doute j'ai un doute sur le gars
et oui
vous avez senti une odeur de gaz avant
oui beaucoup
[Musique]
il y avait
il y avait une eau de gaz une odeur
d'abord bizarre après on l'a identifié
comme du gaz et sur les antennes on
s'interroge le gaz en cause qu'est-ce
qui peut d'autre que le gaz provoquer
une explosion de cette nature on sait
pas ce qu'il y avait dans l'école enfin
c'est il y a eu même vous poser une
bombe j'imagine que ça oui quand même
vous vous posez des drôles de questions
évidemment que si vous posez il y a
plein de choses qui peuvent provoquer
une explosion comment ça va
pas beaucoup pour la fête à midi non non
que ça boit du chocolat chaud
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un célèbre pâtissier français Cédric
Graulhet brocardé pour le prix de sa
tarte aux fraises
quand même quand on va chez un pâtissier
star pâtissier d'un palace Le Meurice on
le Meurisse pardon on perd rarement sa
tarte au prix de la boulangerie du du
quartier il s'agit de cette tarte aux
fraises à l'écran vendu 80 euros chez
Cédric gonna voilà donc 80
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pris la tarte aux fraises Cédric
Rolly 91 voilà à quoi il ressemble il
est trop beau bon en vrai 80 euros si
personne c'est supposé pour ces
personnes le prime chaque passe a fait
ça fait 13 € et quelques la part
franchement le prix me choque c'est
pourquoi on va chez Cédric Grolet
13,60 la part prime chaque pas bon les
fêtes de cette vidéo n'a pas été celui
escompté les internautes ont tous
remarqué que les fraises ne sont même
pas écoutés pendant la journée
l'animateur enchaîne inlassablement les
chèques ananas
à ce rythme on a fait le calcul Paul
fait en moyenne 100 chez gananas par
jour
[Musique]
des internautes qui détournent la tarte
aux fraises de Cédric Grolet et
franchement vous m'avez posé une bonne
question je sais pas j'ai pas goûté si
c'est un trompe l'oeil c'est le droit du
Tremplin ici le crumble avec une pomme
et un sablé classique posé dessus
détail c'est l'étiquette qui est restée
sur la pomme j'aime beaucoup une
variante avec le chausson aux pommes là
c'est très clair
[Rires]
on peut s'amuser à l'infini je trouve
que le cheesecake est pas mal aussi
cheesecake gâteau de fromage voilà un
petit lu
[Applaudissements]
tu vas jouer parce que le cadeau est
incroyable Guillaume tu joueras pour un
super cadeau de fin d'année tu peux
fermer ta gueule
OK
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le trou noir au centre de notre galaxie
n'est pas si endormi qu'on le pensait et
ça c'est quand même un très beau sujet
pour le prochain roman de Bruno Le Maire
on est déjà très impatient qui nous
raconte les mouvements trépidants de ce
renflement noir dilaté comme jamais au
fond de l'espace alors marine oui alors
on parle quand même de 1987 €
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ont répondu à l'appel du large d'une
drôle de manière sacrée champion de
France le weekend dernier avec le Stade
Toulousain romain entama qui est Antoine
Dupont ont trouvé comment surfer sur la
vague du succès avec leur trophée le
Bouclier de Brennus s'est transformé en
planche pour une séance rafraîchissante
diffusée sur leur compte Instagram même
le surfeur Jérémy Florès supporter de
rugby notamment lors du dernier
rassemblement du XV de France a apprécié
la performance et n'a pas hésité à
partager pour se mêler à cette bonne
ambiance
alors que j'attends bêtement encore moi
les premiers livraisons par drone cette
marque annonce la première livraison en
jetpack c'est exactement ce que vous
voyez à l'écran un livreur qui rentre
dans le magasin il charge la pizza et
puis ensuite
qui le rapproche de ces campeurs que
vous allez voir qu'il y avait vraiment
besoin au milieu de la nature comme ça
industriel livré par les airs mais casse
la tienne une fois la livraison
effective voilà plutôt content